hey at seven I gotta get something off
my chest I'm upset with some of you guys
who are watching these videos and are on
my newsletter list and on Facebook and
Twitter who have limiting beliefs that
are holding you back and you fight you
fight to hold on to them even though
it's limiting your growth and your
potential a while ago I made a video
answering a question from one of my
readers who asked something along the
lines of why is it that lady
entrepreneurs don't get the respect that
men do and my response was this has
nothing to do with the fact that you're
a lady and everything to the fact with
the fact that you're not commanding
respect lady entrepreneurs can have just
as much success as men and I know a lot
of women entrepreneurs who are highly
successful who don't take crap who
command respect who have great
businesses and who believe in themselves
and I don't think it's right to love all
women into this category saying that
you're not going to have as much success
because you're a woman now put that on
my newsletter I got a few people writing
back and and one robach her name is Lori
Lori rights in to say hey having just a
quick comment on this as a young female
business owner who commands respect this
is great it's not just a limiting belief
there's enough research out there and
even more testimonials to prove that
it's not an equal playing field yet
although a hundred percent agree that
more women should grow a large set of
balls and thick skin I don't think it's
entirely accurate to say it's a limiting
belief problem especially since you're a
man and haven't experienced this
firsthand hey Lori you know what I can
find stats to back up any argument okay
women entrepreneurship is on the rise
and women might make even better
entrepreneurs they're better
communicating the better collaborating
the better at managing work life than
men are you can find stats that back up
any argument and even if you found stats
what does that do for you if you found
stats that say that women are less
successful as entrepreneurs if you found
stats thats a young entrepreneurs are
less successful or people with accents
are less successful or people from a
different country or less successful
what does that mean for you if you
believe that you're going to be less
successful because you're
woman or because you're young or because
you're from a different country because
you have a disability then that's going
to hold you back you can't believe in
that the reality is people don't care
what people care about is if you can
solve their problem for them if you can
solve their problem they will pay you
and they don't care what your gender is
what color your skin is whatever
disability you might have whatever
accent you might have whatever family
you came from it doesn't matter if you
believe that that's going to hold you
back then it will hold you back it is
just a limiting personal belief and I
did go through it I was never a woman
let me set that straight but I was a
young entrepreneur I was 19 years old I
had my first software company I was
trying to go up make sales that I was
afraid that people would think that
because I was a young entrepreneur they
wouldn't take me seriously and i'm sure
i could find all sorts of start to say
young entrepreneurs aren't a successful
people with more experience so what am I
supposed to do with that am I supposed
to say oh I'm a young entrepreneur it's
really hard i'm not going to make it and
give up no those stats don't help me and
I knew that I alone was in charge of my
destiny and the minute I realized that
these customers of mine or potential
customers didn't care about my age they
only cared about if I could help them
are not the minute i realize that i
started making most more sales i started
making more sales once i bust through
that limiting personal belief so the
fact that you're a woman entrepreneur is
not a negative if you believe that's a
negative then it's always going to hold
you back I don't know why people would
think that's a negative i do not want my
daughter's my sister's my wife to grow
up thinking that because they're women
they have a less chance of being
successful that's not the message i want
to put out there the message should be
because you're an entrepreneur you can
go out and create your own destiny and
yes it's hard running the business is
the hardest thing you ever going to do
in your life it's really really hard
there's a lot of things that are stacked
against you and you're going to have to
bust through them to become successful
but it has nothing to do with the fact
that you're a woman or any other excuse
that you're telling yourself
it's just a story if you change your
story you change your beliefs about
yourself you improve your confidence you
go out there and attack your goals
you're going to achieve success no
matter what statistics may tell you it's
on you good luck go do it guys deep
breath you got me angry anyway for those
of you watching video you liked it
please give me a thumbs up below I love
seeing those come in and I want to hear
you have to think okay let me hear your
thoughts leave a comment below and if
you have a question for your business
leave it in the comment section below i
love seeing those come in thank you guys
I love you guys I'll see you in the next
episode